let's get this out of the way human
penises look weird objectively weird I
mean look at this baboon penis and this
chip penis yeah I said that
look at those penises look at them now
after adjusting for size differences our
primate relatives have much smaller less
detailed penises than humans and those
small penises work just fine because
baby chimps exist so why do humans have
this large black ease boneless veiny
mushroom first let's talk evolution
there are a few theories about why human
penises evolved to look the way they do
Lauretta a cormier hypothesized that
human penises have evolved to be
pleasurable they are large compared to
the penises of other primates and unlike
other primates they don't have a penis
bone allowing for a wider variety of
positions which makes sex more fun and
they don't have penile spines an absence
that requires human males to spend more
time and effort reaching climax Gordon
Gallup hypothesized that human penises
evolved as a specialized tool the semen
displacement theory suggests that
penises evolved to shoot sperm deep into
the vagina and with such force it
displaces any other man's semen while
the mushroom top can scrape old
ejaculate right on out kind of like a
hoe thus attempting to ensure a lady's
most recent hookup is the one that gets
for preggers and while we don't know
exactly why human penises developed into
their current shape we do know that
ancient societies were obsessed with
them some of the first art is penis art
like this cool stick figure guy
nicknamed a little horny man and for
good reason his penis is as big as his
leg jump ahead several thousand years
and we get into some early creation
myths according to ancient texts the
penis created all life the god Enki also
known by the badass nickname organizer
of the universe was thought to have
created the Euphrates River with his
semen according to ancient Egyptian myth
the god autumn created the universe by
masturbating and professor Zion is Evatt
that's a real name has suggested that
God made Eve from Adams missing penis
phone not his rib and that's why the
penis bone is missing around this time
are also some of the first record to
circumcisions being performed it can be
seen on an Egyptian wall relief from
2400 BC
we're not sure quite why it started but
somehow it gained steam and today it's
estimated that more of a third of dudes
have this done let's take it on back to
small penis art because it was pretty
big at the time of the ancient Greeks
check out these famous sculptures of
Hercules and Zeus they all have
relatively small penises compared to
current societies average but why well
the ideal form then included small
tongues and small penises while big
penises were considered humorous you
know like big goofy big dick boys with
Christianity spreading around the globe
came even more tension between men and
their penises Augustine an early
Christian thinker hypothesized that men
resented their own penises because they
separated them from God you know cuz
Mary had never touched one and she was
super pure and she was so cray she had
Jesus and stuff that that's one reason
the European witch trials are also
thought to have been fueled in part by
male anxieties about their penises some
even thought witches were stealing
penises and putting them on a penis tree
the penis trait and in the same crazy
era men would wear codpieces shaped like
full-on erections after the Reformation
culture grew increasingly secular during
the Renaissance with artists often using
metaphors for phallic images Brut took
on erotic associations some we still use
today eggplant emoji slang terms for
penis we're also evolving at the same
time from master John good fallo to
gospel pipe all the way to today's slang
skipping ahead a bit the rise of
commercially available porn may be
influencing the relationship a man has
with his penis
in 1896 the film la coucher de ma da
became known as the first pornographic
film this may have led to more openness
about sex but overall porn may be
skewing perceptions about what the
average penis should look like putting
our culture's penis standards at odds
with the ideal penis standards that the
ancient Greeks had so that brings us to
today now modern medicine can attempt to
change the functionality and appearance
of the penis as men live longer we
invented viagra semaine connections
forever I guess
with the rise of the internet and modern
phones penises are now sent via text
often without request
porn is easily accessible and pills and
creams are marketed to increase penis
size while the penises place in society
has evolved over the millennia our
phallic fixation has and
most likely will remain strong and hard
that is the history of the penis
[Music]